تم حث الحكومة البريطانية على
الإصرار على أن تفرج إيران عن
مواطنيها بما في ذلك نازانين
كدليل على حسن النية قبل العودة إلى
هذه المحادثات
متى ستطلق سراح نازانين
إذا اتهم الناس بأي
شيء وإذا كانت هناك أحكام ضدهم
وكانت هناك مراسيم من قبل  محكمة إذا
كان لديهم جنسية إيرانية ،
فهم يعتبرون مواطنين إيرانيين
ويتم التعامل معهم وفقًا
لذلك ، إذا كان شخص ما يحمل جنسية
دولة أخرى ، فلن يتمتع هذا الشخص
بأي استحقاقات إضافية
ولن يعاني فعليًا من أي نقص
في الامتيازات
هذه المفاوضات أه للحصول عليها  لقد استغرقت الولايات المتحدة
وعودة إيران إلى
الامتثال وقتًا طويلاً ، حيث توقفت المحادثات
في الصيف ، ويبدو أن
لديك أنت والولايات المتحدة
وربما بقية المجتمع الدولي
مطالب
متضاربة ومتضاربة
القضية الرئيسية في  أمامنا هو في
الواقع عودة الولايات المتحدة
إلى التزاماتها داخل jcpoa
وهذا هو
لذا
فإن القضية الرئيسية في المفاوضات القادمة
هي في الواقع إزالة جميع العقوبات غير القانونية
ضد إيران
التي فرضتها الولايات المتحدة ضد
الأمة الإيرانية
فقط حتى أكون واضحًا أنك تريد
رفع العقوبات قبل
إبرام صفقة أو كجزء من
يجب أن تكون هذه الصفقة التي يتم إبرامها جزءًا منها ولكن مسألة
رفع العقوبات يجب أن تصل إلى
نوع من الاستنتاج قبل هذه الأنواع من
المفاوضات.